I've never fed my kids a PB and J sandwich before
and wanted them to know what it tastes like,
so I'm making them uncrustable look alikes
except without all the junk.
Rather than a store bought white bread
that's got synthetic vitamins and preservatives,
I'm making a sourdough bread using all purpose eincorn,
which is the world's most ancient wheat variety
that doesn't upset tummies
and because it still has 85% of the brand,
it's got all the necessary vitamins and minerals
and won't spike insulin.
I got started making a Berry jelly
with some spent berries,
lemon, a tad bit of coconut sugar.
It tastes just like Smuckers
without the high fructose corn syrup and citric acid.
Because I'm making sourdough,
I'll be finishing these sandwiches the next day
and I'll be assembling them for the kids lunch boxes.
I'm not a fan of peanut butter
and it's not allowed at school because of
peanut allergy,
so we'll be using an organic sunflower butter instead.
These are the cutest little uncrustable sandwiches
that taste yummy
yet will leave my kitties with lots of long lasting
energy. And just like Uncrustables,
they can easily be frozen too!